[Music]
a ferocious third wave is sweeping
across africa
more than a dozen nations are reporting
the worst levels of infections
there are 25 000 new cases a day on
average now
three times more than in may
in uganda hospitals are already reaching
capacity
and oxygen is in short supply
[Music]
the amount of oxygen required at the
moment
for the patients as they put you to come
we will not be able to make it the
situation is becoming dire in many
regions
are we seeing a repeat of the indian
tragedy
in africa
[Music]
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin good to have you
with us
now the world health organization says
across the african continent the number
of cases and
deaths increased by almost 40 percent in
the past week
and the third wave hasn't even peaked
yet vaccines as we just heard are in
short supply
as is people's patience with the
uncomfortable pandemic measures
the message shouldn't be new to anyone
one and a half years into a global
pandemic
wash your hands maintain social distance
wear a mask but the disaster management
officers in cape town have observed
that more and more people are not
sticking to the rules
our plea to them is really to consider
their loved ones
even though they may be resistant um to
to
comply with protocol but um they must
think of their family members and their
loved ones at home because how would
they feel
if they carry the virus and they don't
want to comply but they still
infect the people at home and
potentially losing a loved one
not wearing masks in public is a
criminal offence in south africa
yet many people don't but mostly this
mosque in everything is for the rich
people you know what i mean because
they have so a lot of money they don't
want to die poverty is eating us up
it is tiring it is terrible especially
for those who goes to school
like kids now they must go two days
a week like it's all it's frustrating
man it's frustrating a lot of people
close to me
died because of already on the second
wave
so i'm worried on this third wave
so far the province of haoteng around
south africa's economic hub johannesburg
has been hit particularly hard
making up for more than 60 percent of
new infections
scientists expect stricter lockdown
rules soon but will the third wave hit
the entire country harder than the
second
like no we don't expect in the other
areas at least in the coastal provinces
of south africa to be worse than the
second wave
why that is because the second wave was
very severe in the coastal
regions of south africa and we also know
from the science that we have done that
people that got infected with the beta
variant
had released very high level antibodies
so we expect to see
a kind of population immunity around the
coast
so the old choice we're going to take it
too long is that it
taken and uses like in cape town the
disaster management team is encouraging
the elderly to sign up
for a job
now for more on the situation in africa
we talked to yap
boom in cameroon he's professor of
microbiology and the africa
representative for doctors without
borders
specialized in public health my
colleague
terry martin had a chance to talk to him
professor boom
the vaccine shortage is a problem for
the whole african continent
98 of people there remain unvaccinated
the wha estimates that 225 million doses
are still
needed is the continent at risk of being
left behind
i think the continent has already been
left behind
yet we are now in the six months since
the
western country has received a vaccine
and now we are actually struggling to
have some feudals
for some of the countries that are that
are the most exposed
so it is true that all the country
african countries don't
face the same challenges but you us
we're showing south africa they are
really into challenges they don't have
the vaccine
why it has been available globally well
yesterday the who announced plans for
setting up a vaccine production hub in
south africa
how significant is this how fast can it
help
fight the pandemic on the continent
i think first of all it was inevitable
to have the vaccine being produced in
the continent
but for these third wave for this
current
outbreak going on it's a bit late
actually what we need now is to have
those of vaccine available even for even
those one may be laid for country like
uganda south africa and media who are
currently
in the third or in the third wave but
it's already something good
for the upcoming waves and also for the
other diseases
remember that we are going to produce
those vaccine not only for covet
but it might also be important for all
the other diseases for which
we are importing vaccine in africa okay
now we've seen the more transmissible
delta
variant of the coronavirus ravaging
through
india and now rapidly spreading around
the world how worried are you about the
impact it will have on the african
continent
i think we are quite concerned because
if you see the country that are now
quite exposed to the third wave you're
talking about uganda you also have
namibia
kenya those are countries that have
received a lot of travelers
coming from india which mean that they
are more exposed of having that data
variant
and when you look at the populate
population a country like uganda where
we have actually put our original center
on standby
because of the increased number of cases
you will
have a large part of the population who
are having obesity
hypertension diabetes so we are quite
concerned
of the high number of people who might
die and we are already seeing some of
the hospitals that are
at our food so core mobility is uh
playing a role there and you say africa
has already been left behind the
pandemic of course is by
definition a global problem if we fail
to tackle the pandemic properly in
africa
what implications could that have for
the rest of the
you world we are all interdependent
if we don't stop the pandemic in africa
we'll be growing some new variants
and the entire western population that's
already
received the vaccine the pfizer the
modena and all those vaccines at some
point
those virus will come back and they may
vaccine so we are all together maybe we
are not really realizing that enough
we are all interdependent and if africa
is not off of the pandemic
there is no one who will be able to
sleep quietly
nobody is safe till everyone's safe
professor yap boom
africa representative of the research
branch of doctors without border
speaking to us from yandere cameroon
thank you so much
now again again the answer to this
pandemic is vaccination but there
are exceptions perhaps time for your
questions over to derek
my government says people who have had
the disease should get just one dose of
vaccine
because more would be dangerous is that
true
the short answer is is no many
many people who've recovered from covet
19 have since
received a double dose of vaccines
because
the recommendation of most healthcare
authorities in most countries is that
two doses
is still as far as we know the best
way to ensure optimal protection and
and all of those people are fine so we
know it isn't dangerous
to get the full two dose regimen after
recovering from the disease
but there are a few studies that
highlight the question
of whether getting that second shot for
those people
makes sense one in particular that was
published in the journal nature
back in april it's received a lot of
attention
the us researchers involved discovered
that
antibody response in people who'd
recovered from the disease
that it soared after they got the first
shot
of a messenger rna vaccine tights that
are only seen after
after two shots in someone who's never
been infected
so although it won't hurt you to get a
second dose of vaccine
after recovering from covid19
many experts now think that it also
won't have really a dramatic
impact on how well you're protected
at some point a kind of law of
diminishing returns kicks in where
we're giving someone who recovered
more vaccine likely won't really improve
their immune response much anymore
because
their body is already locked and loaded
to fight off sarsko v2 um that's
prompted for example
um the french authorities to recommend
that people who've had covet 19 already
only get one shot because that's all the
experts there think
is needed for good protection
that advice might change in the future
but particularly in countries where
vaccines are currently scarce
holding off on the second shot in people
who've had the disease
could allow authorities to spread the
limited vaccines they have
a lot further
[Music]
derek williams will be back again next
week no doubt about that
that's all from this kobe 19 special
thanks for watching
you